Romilly those are the five step sorry
sorry sorry so I hear things like
Richard Branson's physio so he's very
[Applause]
[Music]
here we on an auction house in London
and I'm gonna be speaking shortly and
after that there's going to be an actual
auction so who knows I might end up
buying something we'll say but great to
be here some good people good network in
always good to put yourself in these
kind of environments and looking forward
to speaking I've got to prepare my
7-minute all that but doing a 7-minute
talk is hard because you you've got to
make it super concise so excited man
homes into the Hamrick coming as well so
I might meet my friend Martin Roberts I
doubt it but there's gonna be a lot of
filming going on people doing selfies
and Instagram lives feel right at home I
like to buy houses in
non-article for areas I just bought one
two months ago in Doncaster Doncaster is
going to become an article for area in
October I've just bought a family home
last month in Doncaster I'm gonna just
put a bed in the rooms and then in
October when article four comes in I
will have automatic planning permission
grandfather rights in which case
probably the value is going to go up
[Music]
[Music]
it is for a house man this auction is
the fastest way to buy a house the best
way to make quick money and to make a
lot money is from auction but the best
way to lose money as well as from
auction so auction is fantastic but you
need some what you're doing because you
know what they do they get you all
pumped up you know your emotions are
high and when your emotions are high
sometimes your intelligence can be low
so I'm gonna come back next time I'm
gonna buy a house for next time I'll
come to auction but before before you
come to an auction you need to know what
you want to buy what the maximum amount
is that you'll buy because you see how
these guys play play each other against
one another but a great man love it
great for networking as well it's like
the best kind of networking and it's
free for anyone can come to this so get
yourself books on an auction but make
sure you do not make a stupid mistake
it's a lot better another fall I've got
full range okay but it's just I need to
build a stroke back at the moment so I
can promise you this one this one I can
lock it kind of it's a better shape yeah
I've also not of definitely this one is
nowhere near as long as this one it's
not skinnier it's also if I but this leg
I can do that
where is this leg about that far shape
so you know sometimes as well sometimes
when I'm walking I just just jolt it's
not hundred percent so I just want to
keep focus on it work doing the
exercises it's pretty good
[Music]
hey yeah right so you're crazy
well I'm thinking what we like to be
having suddenly will be sales yeah we're
not more than now we will okay yeah yeah
yeah that's crying
[Music]
so this is actually we're going to
convert this into serviced offices let
the rest of the building so we just
created a little sort of interview set
[Laughter]
three years since 2016 yes it is we get
turning people sometimes we we do a
special and sometimes we get about 350
or so well let's see it is we've done
some surveys and stuff and when we put
out YouTube videos people do come and
join us at the event no doubt about it
people like the content people like the
people like to get off network YouTube
and meet people yes and shake their
hands and business and all that sort of
stuff we are doing interview that's it
yeah
[Music]
mate well what we wanted to do you know
you know my situation you know we're
pretty significant probably imagine the
kind of profits when I came from our
business if you made would you be
wanting to invest that into commercial
but now they're paying a pretty horrible
stuff though isn't it's not pretty
it is six years left of the lease who
cares yeah cause the very electric
anyway there'll be be fun but they're
using their v8 usage yeah yeah would you
suggest people getting to commercial
property before they learn any less than
she's not a fair thing to do it would
you say that should get their teeth into
residential fast
[Music]
if it ends we'll be doing in the
workshops enough this is a great
opportunity think about it in floor
space
yeah we're dealing with the building
where two-thirds of the floor space is
known to you if you've got a shot or to
close about two-thirds of this wall
space is residential and known to you
third is view yeah people tell you to
target tired landlords yeah but don't
you ever think why they're tired and
don't you ever think that when you're
their age you're gonna be tired too
you're right yeah okay so what the hell
are you doing come on target I'd say
well I disagree I don't see I'd say I
disagree that I love it
I did because everyone has seasons when
I started out in property when I was 17
18 all I wanted to be busy with property
so I'm finding tired landlords and I'm
buying their HMOs I'm taking their
properties on regiments ammo but I want
their problems because for me make an
extra two three ground them up is a
massive two there and they're like done
they want to just live in Spain and
retire there 65 years old so I'm taking
on so I think that's I think that's
where I would probably did the other
sides of the coin that's by that was me
but now you are a point you're at a
point now where you're saying look man I
want needs life now when 20 years time
we have
you'll be telling me how you're
migrating to easier asset to Bintang no
I'll be telling you that night light in
two months because I'm already there
I've got over 100 tenants I've got a lot
of residential properties I'm making a
lot of money now I want to start pumping
it on that 100 100 hectare nice I don't
want it I mean the other thing that I
find with the you could be far more
diverse in job with residence property
really maximize your return by having a
geographical concentration commercial
stuff stuff what kind of stuff does Lord
Sugar buy what'swhat's Lord Sugar's it
was drug today and what kind of stuff
does he buy did you know he said he
didn't know anywhere property so he went
around Oxford Street and recent streams
or that those we have that's what the
three hollers yeah
just feel cuz I merge it out Lord Sugar
had their trading business yeah yeah and
the problem with trading businesses
they're hugely risky so he was making a
ton of money out of his trading
businesses and you know how to invest I
don't know you probably got more minutes
before your time what Amstrad be is they
bought a hundred in the eighties yeah
yeah
Sinclair they bought quite sinclair
computer business spectrums and all of
that he paid one hundred and fifty
million pound for this company and
within three years he was worth five
million
it's only five minute yeah and then he
realized that trading businesses just to
risk so you could lose everything but
it's very difficult by a hundred fifty
million pound with the property lots of
three reasons three and have it come
down to five million yeah course
something happened Jason so you know yes
he's on TV with the apprentice and all
of that but the majority of his business
his property and again with the Dragons
Den people and once people get
successful in the trading business the
less risky way to preserve what they've
built is through property yeah
commercial for James card all of these
guys if they all do poverty and those
are the five top ways to buy property
using not itself I knew that guy from
YouTube I mean I seen you on YouTube are
you Samuel Bradford or something so on
dude what what are you feeling anyway
I'm talking about how to buy residential
property listen make this one mechanism
at the action is buying commercial
property with no money down and that's
what I'm speaking about in an event I've
seen anything to set them back videos
they're good but you make something
commercial so complex and so on that's
why you know what your guys you you guys
need to hear about how to buy
residential property using none of their
own money okay listen I bet you're gonna
tell me you're not free if you're free
wednesday 25th of september central
london you come down and share with the
Baker Street crowd five ways to buy
residential property with no money down
I'll share five ways to buy commercial
property with no money down
let them decide well what's the really
fifth of September what do you want in
your hair 25th of September challenge
accepted I'm challenge accepted okay
then what just battle it out big Street
property meet Wednesday 25th of
September be their tickets below Baker
Street property meet calm see you there
guys
[Music]